les rues de port au prince noir de fumée
de résultats de la colère des haïtiens
face aux pompes à essence désespérément
à sac la pénurie paralyse les activités
journalières et économique
nous ne pouvons pas vivre sans carburant
le gouvernement doit prendre ses
responsabilités des corriger la
situation
sans pétrole
les taxis par exemple ne roule plus leur
chauffeur sans revenu accuse le chef de
l'état le président moïse refuse de
démissionner la croissance en 2010 neuf
devraient stagner à 1,5 pour cent comme
l'an dernier mais l'inflation annuelle
atteint 17% pour marché noir le litre
d'essence avoisine les 3 euros dans un
pays où le salaire mensuel moyen
n'atteint pas 60 euros